hola buenos días pues las reacciones
desde bruselas no se han hecho esperar
ha habido una declaración de la
presidenta de la comisión europea ursula
von der leyen que ha asegurado que el
anuncio de este corte de suministro es
utilizar el gas como un instrumento de
chantaje y ha avisado ya avanzado que
los países europeos ya se estaban
preparando con planes de contingencia
ante escenario posible también la
presenta de la del parlamento europeo
robert ha hecho la ha asegurado que
ahora sí este es el momento de dejar de
depender por completo de los
combustibles fósiles de rusia tal y como
votó recientemente la eurocámara también
el jefe de la diplomacia europea se
aburre en la misma línea ha asegurado
que ahora mismo dejar de depender de los
combustibles fósiles de rusia es más
urgente que nunca hay que tener en
cuenta que la unión europea es muy
dependiente tanto del gas como del
petróleo de rusia aproximadamente
importa un 40 por ciento del gas pero
aún así no ha dejado de ser un jarro de
agua fría para la unión europea esta
decisión así es esther le preguntó
entonces qué puede pasar ahora cuáles
son los escenarios es
pues ahora es que no sabemos qué es lo
que puede ocurrir si rusia también
tomará medidas frente a otros países
europeos y también les cortará el gas de
momento hungría ha asegurado que el gas
sigue fluyendo en su caso porque llegó a
un acuerdo en que podía pagar en euros y
así luego poderlo convertir en rublos
los pagos del gas pero la decisión ahora
mismo podría redoblar la presión a las
capitales europeas que actualmente están
negociando un posible embargo del
petróleo y del gas pero es una cuestión
muy divisiva hay países como por ejemplo
precisamente hungría que lo están
evitando que están bloqueando esta
decisión pero no es casualidad que rusia
haya tomado esta decisión sabe que es
una cuestión muy decisiva y podría
dividir muchísimo más a los países que
hasta ahora ha mostrado una gran unidad
frente a las sanciones el frente a las
sanciones contra rusia hay que tener en
cuenta que aún así la comisión europea
propuso reducir dos tercios este mismo
año la dependencia del gas ruso pérez no
será nada fácil y como ya se comentaba
la inflación puede subir y también los
precios